- Never stop learning.
We see HelloFresh everyday as
an new learning opportunity.
I think the moment that you
stop learning and developing
is the moment in which the company
ultimately is going to stop growing and
improving as you want it to.
(electronic music)
I'm Ed Boyes.
I run the US operations at HelloFresh.
HelloFresh is an online
grocery delivery service.
We make it easier for people to cook
delicious recipes at home.
We do that by eliminating
every single obstacle
that you have to home cooking.
Our consumers don't like
going to the grocery store,
don't like waiting in a line.
They struggle to find new
recipes and new ideas.
So we take all of those
struggles away from them
by sending them a box with
the exact fresh ingredients
and step-by-step recipes to
make it really easy and simple.
So I joined the team at the very beginning
to launch and run the UK business.
We started very early on
in several European markets
really kind of try to
figure out the concept
and how it works.
We had a really successful
few years in Europe,
and then over the course of
the last couple of years,
we really expanded in the US,
so I went over to run the US operation.
Now we deliver over nine million
meals per month globally.
So the challenges of being young in
such a rapidly growing
company in many ways
I see it more as an opportunity.
At an earlier stage in your
career, I think you have
the ability to be very agile,
move quickly and evolve.
We've historically actually hired people
for trajectory rather than
experience level at HelloFresh
and really if we want to have
a business which evolves and grows and
really defines a new
category on a global level,
we think it's far more
important that people have
an agile, nimble attitude
to growing the business.
So I think one of my career highlights
actually came before my
career even started, so
I was very keen sportsman
as a teenager growing up,
and then had a couple
of terrible injuries,
and those terrible
injuries led me to putting
my competitive intensity into
entrepreneurial endeavors.
Started a couple of businesses, age 16,
completely unsuccessful but really
gave me the entrepreneurial bug.
In the early stages of developing
a company from scratch,
it's really all about hustling.
You know when you go into corporate life,
people have three month road maps.
They have 12-month strategies.
In starting a new business,
and getting something
off the ground, you don't
even have a one day strategy.
So it's really about
kind of focusing on the
imminent challenges ahead of you and
kind of really hustling and really
kind of making things happen.
(electronic music)